[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Lewis Carroll's Adventures in Wonderland
from the very moment Alice falls down
that rabbit hole or a mind-bending
journey through a dream Mary Shelley's
Masterpiece Frankenstein and mendeleev's
periodic table they were inspired by
dreams Vincent van Gogh once noted I
dream my painting and I paint my dream
whether or not we remember them most of
us dream every time we go to sleep our
dreams they have delighted us frightened
us mystified us and become enmeshed with
our Collective psyche for thousands of
years humans have attempted to make
sense of these transformative nightly
Journeys from the ancient Egyptians and
Greeks who imagined dreams as messages
from the gods to Aristotle who rejected
the idea that dreams were orchestrated
by the heavens instead believing they
related to real Waking Life to Freud two
thousand years later who took it a step
further declaring dreams the royal road
to the unconscious but with Freud's
psychoanalysis being cast as soft
science at best not to mention dreams
having also been the purview of fortune
tellers and psychics for a long time
dreams were considered beyond the scope
of rigorous scientific investigation
until that is the 1950s when a grad
student named Eugene essarinsky observed
the flickering nighttime eye movements
of his eight-year-old son thereby
discovering REM rapid eye movement sleep
this breakthrough showed that the
sleeping brain is in an active not a
passive State and launched the modern
era of dream exploration
now scientists have gone further still
and crafted techniques to communicate
with so-called lucid dreamers those are
dreamers who within their dreams are
aware that they are dreaming and these
developments they may help us unlock the
mysteries of dreaming and perhaps
illuminate the nature of Consciousness
itself
so in tonight's program we'll explore
some of the age-old questions like why
do we dream and what do these nocturnal
Visions mean as well as some newer ones
like can we harness our dreams to Foster
creativity to solve problems to even
prepare us for the future Emily Bronte
once said dreams have gone through and
through me like wine through water and
altered the color of my mind so let's
follow Emily bronte's lead and journey
together into the chromatic casts cues
and shades of the human mind after
midnight
[Music]
[Music]
our first guest is Deirdre Barrett who
is a lecturer and dream researcher at
Harvard Medical School she has written
five books including pandemic dreams and
the committee of sleep and is the editor
of the journal dreaming Deirdre focuses
her study on the intersection of
dreaming creativity and problem solving
she joins us from New York City Welcome
Deirdre our next guest is Antonio zadra
who is a professor in the psychology
department at the University of Montreal
and an investigator at the center for
advanced research in sleep medicine
Tony's work explores lucid dreams
nightmares and parasomnias and he
co-authored the book when brains dream
understanding the science and mystery of
our dreaming Minds he joins us from
Montreal welcome Tony and finally we
have Professor Ken pallor who is the
director of the cognitive Neuroscience
program at Northwestern University
his work focuses on sleep memory and
Consciousness and the recent
groundbreaking research he conducted
with colleagues around the world proves
that real-time two-way communication
with lucid dreamers is possible he joins
us from Evanston Illinois welcome Ken
and welcome to you all thank you all so
much for joining us for this discussion
so I just want to begin with a general
question of what is it about dreaming
what is it about this kind of virtual
reality playground of the mind that we
each engage in every night what makes
dreaming so captivating Tony thoughts on
the staying power of dreams as a piece
of Fascination for this species well I
think we've always been fascinated by
two questions
one what are these experiences that we
are having while we are asleep and two
where do they come from
and I think those two questions have
driven people's desire to understand the
nature and possible meaning of dreams
and
um and again where are we when we are
immersed in these Virtual Worlds and how
does a body that from the outside
appears inert asleep
often viewed as the a cousin of death
how is it generating these really
compelling experiences where we meet
people we get chased we fall in love so
I think I
cross-culturally and historically we've
been fascinated by why do we have these
experiences where do they take place and
what meaning if any do they hold dear
terrific thoughts on that I mean it's
just these amazing things happen to us
during the night and although some
cultures teach about looking to dreams
for creative ideas or wisdom or believe
that they're communicating with
ancestors or Gods I think it's just
absolutely natural you just see a young
child even in a family that's not
talking about dreams at all will start
recounting these amazing things that
happen to them during the night I I
think it's just in the nature of the
experience to Fascinate us yeah can any
any thoughts on that yeah and it's
striking that some people are really
wonderful at telling stories of creating
stories and so we think certain people
have a great capacity for that but in
fact all of us invent these wonderful
stories every night in our dreams so we
all have that capacity and it kind of
stands next to what our waking
experiences are like when uh ordinary
things are happening and we don't have
the same creativity of just telling a an
incredible Story the way our brain seems
to operate during sleep yeah I know it's
an amazing thing throughout history
there have been many theories about why
we dream from evolutionary necessity to
the possibility that dreaming is just
sort of meaningless firings inside the
brain while we sleep and so what are
some of the ideas that people have put
forward in the past for why we dream
okay well there's many when we ask the
question do dreams of a function what
we're asking is do these virtual reality
hallucinatory experiences we have during
the night have a function their messages
from the gods was one of the first ones
again we're going where do they come
from well the gods are sending them to
us and if they're busy sending us
messages then you know they must have
value there's also ideas from Freud uh
you know the dreams serve as the
expression of suppressed wishes so
dreams give disguised forms to these
wishes which are acceptable to us
um Jung came along and had a more broad
holistic and positive review of dreams
as helping our well-being but if we talk
about more contemporary models of Dreams
there is for instance the threat
simulation theory of dreams that posits
that one of the evolutionary advantages
of dreams for our ancestors was that
they could rehearse potentially
dangerous situations they could rehearse
threats and appropriate responses to
them so it's a a virtual reality
simulator that helps prepare us for real
life dangers that group headed by auntie
ravanzo a philosopher neuroscientists in
Finland recently had another version of
this which is social simulation function
of Dreams which is dreams we don't we're
very rarely alone in our dreams we're
often interacting with others so there's
a very strong social component and so
the idea is that dreams might help us
decipher visual cues in others their
intentions and form social bonds and
that that has an Adaptive value
dreams are for regulating emotions now
we know that REM sleep plays an
important role in regulating our
emotions but there's also some evidence
that may be dreaming itself plays a role
in these processes and so there's all of
these different ideas that dreams also
might help us solve problems and I'm
sure Deirdre has a lot of wonderful
examples also about that historically
and and also in more recent research
really I'd really like to jump in with
something know because I agree with my
most of what Tony said but my take is a
little bit different and maybe more
evolutionary specific perspective which
is when people ask me that I'm always
struck that they they would never ask
that about what is waking thought for or
at least they wouldn't ask it and think
maybe there was a one phrase or a one
sentence answer and the fact that that
serious theories Freud's about dreams
being wish fulfillment and Dr
revenantsu's about dreams being threat
simulation if you think about them they
are as opposite as you can get and if we
were talking about waking thought we we
would think of course it's for both
those things plus a lot others and yet
theories will say dreams are just for
this one thing or dreams are just for
that one thing and I think that what
people sometimes don't understand about
evolution is that a very recent
development in Behavior structure is
likely to have one purpose but the the
sleep cycle with rapid eye movement
sleep is a very separate stage of sleep
approximately dates back to the start of
mammals so an enormous amount of
evolutionary history and I think that
certainly that the Sleep stage probably
developed to replenish certain
neurotransmitters that were getting used
up too rapidly when being awake to it's
actually the time when body temperature
regulation shuts down I mean there's
some very obviously biological things
happening during rapid eye movement
sleep but then I think the best
demonstrated function has to do with
certain types of memory consolidation
some happen more in non-rem but some
happen the more emotional ones happen
more in rem so I think it's like a
layering like they're these physiologic
needs that it's serves for even those
primitive mammals and then there are
simple cognitive things that it serves
for most mammals just on and on up but I
think humans because they've had the
state of so much visual imagery and
narratives and I have no trouble with
the neurological types who say that's
determined because of some biological
need but I think once we've had that for
all of human history that we're getting
some functions layered on top of that
that if we're going to spend all this
much time in states where our brains
make looser associations and can
hallucinate Nate visual imagery that
we've started using that for enhancing
creativity around visual spatial things
for helping us think outside the box
when we're stuck on on in our waking
thought so I just think it's it's just
as complicated as as waking thought in
all the functions that maybe serving and
so so Ken do any of these resonate with
you do you think it's a combination of
all the above I would add another
perspective from Neuroscience to think
about dreams I really want to think
about it together with thinking about
sleep so how is it that sleep
contributes to our memory functions and
to that I need to back up a little bit
and say well how do we learn new new
things how do we gain new information
and when humans are learning information
doesn't necessarily stick immediately
and we we know that you have to rehearse
information and so we know that learning
depends on not just acquiring some
information initially but a prolonged
process we call consolidation where the
information we learned gets integrated
with other things we know so now we have
evidence from multiple sources that that
happens during sleep and a lot of the
work has been focusing on slow wave
sleep because there's been sort of very
consistent evidence showing that slow
wave sleep is beneficial for Learning
and in fact looking at the of physiology
we can see that those slow waves are
part of the story because those slow
waves make it possible for communication
between different brain regions to be
efficient and then we have to say can
that connect to why we dream and why we
remember dreams later and that's sort of
the newer work that's looking at that
because in the studies of slow wave
sleep we're not asking people what
dreams they remember
and in fact when you consolidate
memories during slow wave sleep you wake
up without any knowledge you were doing
that in fact interestingly when you go
to sleep and wake up after some time you
might think your brain was off the whole
time the way my laptop computer does
nothing when
it goes to sleep when you turn it off
the information that was there at the
moment you turned it off is still there
in a static form when you turn it Wick
when you wake up when the computer wakes
up again and you want to extract that
information but our brains are quite
different and that information is
getting turned around during sleep and
it makes sense that perhaps the dreams
that we recall are connected with this
process of integrating information that
we've acquired recently with the
information that we've stored over the
prior parts of our life and figuring out
what's important and how does that
information relate to say our future
goals or problems we're having at the
moment but this churning over of
information during sleep and perhaps
during dreams seems to be perhaps part
of the process where we can effectively
have information that we're going to
need later and why do we need that
information well reminiscing is nice so
it's great if you can think about your
memories but of course you want that
information to inform the decisions you
make and to be good at creative problem
solving later and so for those reasons
you want to have consolidation work and
uh that could work without our knowledge
completely unconsciously so it's still a
mystery why is there some remnant of
that when you wake up in the form of
these dreams if that's not a necessary
component of the consolidation process
going forward and as Tony was saying you
don't necessarily need to remember those
dreams perhaps for the process to be
effective whatever's happening in REM
sleep and in non-ram sleep can be
effective even if we don't know about it
when we wake up so you made reference to
memory consolidation during sleep there
is evidence for that now that that is
something that happens inside of our
heads while we're sleeping there's many
sources of evidence showing that the
more slow waves that appear the better
memory is when you wake up there's some
studies you know not just correlating
what happens but actually manipulating
the process Can Be an Effective sign
scientific approach so this is a method
that we call targeted memory
reactivation and what that method allows
us to do is ask well if particular
memories are activated when you're
asleep are there any repercussions
usually we present some sensory
information but very subtly so that it
doesn't disturb sleep and the sensor
information can be like a prompt to make
you rehearse and if you want to rehearse
when you're awake maybe you get a little
of the information you're trying to
think about and you recall the rest of
it and every time you do that that's
helping the memories be stronger a cat's
meow can be a prompt is a The Not So
subtle sound effect that we're hearing
right now ah that's what I was hearing
yes so and so in some of our experiments
in fact we have people learn locations
of objects and they may learn 50
different objects and each one has a
sound like the cat has a meow sound the
kettle has a whistle of the kettle sound
every object has a sound and people
don't need to learn the sounds what they
need to do is learn where exactly are
those objects where was that kettle last
time I saw it and they learned exactly
where it goes and then they also can be
reminded of that location with the sound
so we present those sounds as they're
learning and then we again present some
of those sounds very quietly while
they're in slow wave sleep and those
sounds connect with their memories for
that information and remind them and in
fact make them think of the locations of
those objects and we suspect that's
happening because when people wake up
they are remembering the locations for
the objects that we had them reactivate
during sleep and so this has been done
with spatial knowledge with verbal
knowledge with lots of other things we
published a study recently this year
with face name learning so when you
learn the names of people
of course you want to practice those so
that when you see that face again you
can say oh hi glad to meet you Brian and
and remember that name later and so when
a memory is reactivated it's not just
played again but it it's actually
strengthening the neural network that
stores that information so that it
improves uh increases the chances that
you can recall that information later so
Tony what do you think there's
overwhelming evidence that one of the
things that sleep does cognitively is
enhance our memory so to consolidate
memories but memory consolidation is
more like when you are learning a fact
you sort of want to stabilize the memory
and so that sort of makes animals or
mammals are us kind of smart if you want
but how and when you use that
information what's makes people wise and
we think that that's where dreaming
comes in that's where you need these
hallucinatory experiences and so what is
important how does it fit into what
we've learned recently and we know that
dream content isn't random you can see
patterns in individuals and also the
kinds of information and events and
thoughts that get Incorporated in our
dreams aren't random the brain has a
preference for emotionally Salient
events or concerns and that's what gets
integrated into dreams most and we think
that maybe what the brain is doing
particularly in REM sleep is exploring
in a way that you would never do while
you were awake very weak associations it
takes this experience we had and goes
what is there in our semantic Registries
that sort of tie into this so it's
opening different drawers and seeing
does it relate to this does it relate to
this and one way the brain can figure
out if it's on a good path or not is how
are you the dreamer reacting to these
associations in in the dream and this
feedback loop which evolves over time as
the narrative unfolds in this very
unique as the address said biochemical
state that is REM sleep in particular
explores all these things to try to make
sense and to create these memories as
Ken said not to memory is not there to
reminisce memories help us understand
what is coming up and how to adapt to
the Future world and so I think that in
dreams your brain is doing something
very similar but in a much more
metaphorical abstract loosely associated
way which is why dreams have this
inherent bizarreness your dream is
exploring in what way can this material
be useful and so it's not just
consolidating memories it's taking them
it's weaving them into our
autobiographical memories our
understanding of ourselves our place in
the world and what might happen in the
future and that might entail emotional
regulation it might entail creativity
sometimes so returning back to Deirdre I
agree that the dreaming brain can do
much more than one thing and it's all
layered and depending what kind of
challenges you're facing where you are
in your development in your age and what
challenges we Face covid Wars what
trauma
um your your brain is going to be
creating different kinds of narrative
scenarios because it's trying to adapt
to the Future and that's what allows the
species to survive and so so given that
clear articulation of the potential uh
evolutionary adaptive role of dreaming
across the spectrum of ways in which we
human beings can be better prepared to
engage with the challenges of the world
I want to turn to a type a specific type
of dreaming that I think is less
familiar to the general public than the
kind of everyday or should I say every
night version of dreaming where we go to
sleep and dreams just kind of happen to
us there's a there's a version of
dreaming called lucid dreaming that you
all are intimately familiar with but
frankly I had never even heard of it
until relatively recently and in fact I
realized that I had a lucid dream before
I knew what the term lucid dream even
meant I mean just very very quickly I'm
not asking to be psychoanalyzed here but
um there was a renovation happening in
the apartment across the way from ours
and I was invited in in my dream world
it was a real renovation happening and
they took me around and it was crazy in
there there were stages and performers
and circus all this crazy stuff but what
really caught my attention was the
height of the ceiling
because I knew that the ceiling couldn't
be that high so I said to the contractor
how'd you get the ceiling so high he
said well the outside of the building
has a different shape in this part of
the building and in the dream I said to
myself that's not true I know what this
building looks like this must be a dream
and I said to myself in the dream I'm
going to wake myself up and prove that
this is a dream and I ship myself in the
dream and I shook myself in real life
and I woke up and and so I'd never had
that that experience before it was kind
of a a wild moment for me but I but I
gather that this is something now which
um science really can confirm that there
is this thing called lucid dreaming
where you can be in a dream and know
that you're in the dream so Ken you've
actually done some some work on this
really establishing scientifically that
that lucid dreaming is a real thing can
you tell us about that yeah I think it's
been established that it was real for
quite a while but we had some additional
questions one of our questions was can
we do better with dream research because
right now we find out about dreams only
when you wake up and you wake up you're
in a different stage your brain is in
quite a different stage and you forget a
lot of your dreams as we were discussing
earlier probably you remember only a
small fraction of your dreams and you
may distort the parts you do remember or
forget details and so we thought well
dream research would be better equipped
to understand dreams if we could also
look at the brain during a dream and
find out what people are experiencing
but we wanted to be able to ask people
what they're experiencing and we thought
while they're while they're sleeping
while they're sleeping if we could not
wait for them to wake up and tell us
about their dream but ask them during
the dream questions about what they're
dreaming then we would be better
equipped to continue our studies and try
to understand dreams and how they relate
to memory processing and creativity and
so forth so we set out to do that and
there are two challenges one is to have
someone in a sleep lab in the midst of a
lucid dream and the other was to show
that you can actually communicate with
them because lucid dreaming as you
mentioned is a bit rare not everyone
does it even people that do it don't
necessarily have a dream every time they
would come to the sleep lab and and so
we needed to provoke lucid dreaming and
so we basically took the method I had
been using in slow wave sleep targeted
memory reactivation and to try to
transfer that to REM sleep and so
instead of having people learn the
locations of objects before sleep we had
them learn a strategy of how to think
carefully about the present moment and
carefully decide am I awake right now
or am I in the midst of a dream so we
trained them to do that for a few
minutes before sleep together with an
important sound so there was some sound
that cued them to go into that State of
Mind of carefully checking it might be a
little violin
or or the sound of a harp some beeping
noises and we use some lights as well so
different sorts of sensory stimulation
that we could then present again when we
know they're in REM sleep so they do the
training with the sound they get the
sound again during REM sleep and that
often provokes people to have a lucid
dream and so our first part of the
challenge was successful we can maybe
met make even half of the people have a
lucid dream when we present those sounds
with that procedure the targeted memory
reactivation or we call it targeted
Lucidity activation in this case and so
but how do we know they're having a
lucid dream well we had to give them
some instructions and so it's been known
that lucid dreamers can move their eyes
in their dream body and their actual
eyes will move to and we can put
electrodes on their face and record that
those eye movements and if you make an
eye movement to the left and to the
right very far in the distance left
right left right we can record that
activity from our electric physiological
measurements and that you know in Rapid
Eye move and sleep you see some eye
movements but you seldom see the all the
way to the left to right left right
movement so it's a very distinctive
signal we can be very confident when we
see it that the dreamer is signaling to
us understand that they're in in the
midst of a dream so we've established
that they're having a lucid dream and
they've given us the signal now what
wasn't known before was whether people
could receive information and
communicate back and so that's what we
did in my lab and also several labs in
Europe that we published together we
showed that well if we ask a question
to a lucid dreamer they can give us an
answer back with eye movements or a few
other modes of expressing themselves
that are available to them of course
because they can't talk their body is
mostly paralyzed so they're unable to
just sort of give us an answer to the
question but with eye movement signals
or some muscle twitches or what we're
using now sniffing signals we can
measure responses from people because of
course your respiration is still working
during sleep and you can control that
and you can sniff and we can put a
cannula near the nose to measure that
sniff response what sort of question so
we wanted to ask questions where we knew
what the correct answer was not
something about their dream but
something where we could verify it was
the correct answer so we settled on math
problems little math problems there
would be addition or subtraction and the
answer might be one two three or four
and they would be told move your eyes
left to right the number of times for
the answer to the question and therefore
they could answer the question and so
we've repeated this with other subjects
a number of times it doesn't work every
time but it's been repeated enough in
our lab and other labs for us to know
that we are successfully communicating
that people can hear a question they can
think about it they can you know
understand it correctly do a mental
computation little addition or
subtraction and decide what the answer
is and then produce the answer with
their eye movement signals so that we
can confirm that we've communicated
correctly and now we're moving ahead to
ask more interesting questions besides
math problems to find out well what are
they dreaming at the moment what is
their experience of the moment and then
asking and what's the brain activity at
the same time and how do we relate those
two so we can understand more and more
about dreaming and what do the
participants say after they wake up do
they remember being asked a question and
do they remember the process by which
they came to the answer in the dream
state yes interestingly not always do
they remember but many times people
remember the question and so they would
wake up they would tell us what they
were dreaming dreaming there are other
people that heard the question coming
from some aspect of the dream so one
person was in a car and it sounded like
the questions were coming from the car
radio
another dreamer thought it was coming
from the ceiling just like some someone
talking to them out of nowhere uh and of
course some people don't don't respond
at all so they may not have a lucid
dream where they may not uh have the
capacity for the information to come
from the outside into their dream but
but here's the interesting part you
might think well how do we remember
dreams we remember a small fraction of
our dreams but if you have a lucid dream
you must remember that because your
brain is in this different state but
actually we found that some people
communicate during a dream they get a
question they answer correctly and then
some minutes later we wake them up and
they don't remember it happening so in
fact even a lucid dream isn't
necessarily stored effectively our brain
is in such a different state that we're
not necessarily storing the experience
which as you were discussing earlier
it's kind of adaptive that you know we
don't want to mix up things that really
happened with things we experienced in a
dream or even in the waking state things
we imagine happening we need to keep
those separate so like we don't get
offended of our friends for doing
something that they didn't actually do
it yeah no I always get I always get
angry at my wife for what she does in
the dream world and she goes along with
it strangely enough and recognizes that
somehow this is a reality for me but
Tony rumor has it that you are a
proficient Lucid dreamer is there one
that you want to share with us that is
particularly telling of the experience I
once had a dream where I'm met Carl Jung
and he was telling me all these
wonderful ideas about the psyche and how
lucid dreaming fits into this and I
realized I was dreaming but I thought
I'm not going to be able to remember all
of this when I wake up and so my clever
solution I decided to take notes
of course when I woke up my notes
weren't there so your logic injuries you
might think you're logical but you're
not really and so it's even in lucid
dreams it's very hard to maintain your
attention and your critical sense all
that they say becoming Lucid is one
thing and and yourself you mentioned you
became Lucid in your dream then you woke
up but staying Lucid that is having that
critical frame of mind and not falling
back into non-lucid dreaming and not
getting too excited to wake up can be a
really fine line so I think it's it's
much more challenging than many people
maybe portray it to be and Deirdre I
understand that you've conducted
research on lucid dreaming what have you
learned I did a study which ended up
under the title just how Lucid or lucid
dreams where I came up with four
corollaries that seem like just some of
the most basic things if you knew
completely logically all the
implications that this is a dream you
should know these things and they were
that dream characters are not the real
people they are your representation of
them that dream objects are not real and
you cannot bring them back from the
dream world that you should have
memories of your Waking Life rather than
either amnesia for it or made up things
um and oh that you don't have to how
could I forget this in front of Brian
that you don't have to obey the laws of
physics in a dream what I found was that
only half the dreams where the dreamer
knew it was a dream were Lucid on any
one of these corollaries and only
one-fourth were Lucid on all of them
then for objects people sometimes wanted
to bring back one object just to prove
they were in this dream world but others
were trying to take notes because they
realized that they didn't always recall
their dreams in all its detail and and
you would just see examples where people
would say this is a dream and then on
the dream character one they'd start
talking to someone and go my God We're
Dreaming so as soon as we wake up I'm
gonna call you and we're going to
compare notes to see if we remember the
same thing from the dream that one
cropped up repeatedly there was another
one that was rolling back that I didn't
like the way that happened I'm going to
change it and have a different outcome
and they'd sort of roll back the action
and Roll It Forward and they substituted
one person for another and they said I
know I can do that because I'm the
director of this play I'm a theater
director so I can I can change the plan
the action and and try as many versions
as I want because I'm directing this
play yeah so so it's just amazing that
the sort of Lucidity is such a Continuum
and you know it has yeah I mean speaking
speaking of uh characters in in lucid
dreams there's a there's an artist in
the UK Named Dave green no no
relationship to me I don't know I think
some of you may know him but you know I
interacted with him over the course of a
couple days and he through the process
of being able to put himself in a lucid
dream was able to be the director as
Deidre is saying and conjure me in his
dream and much like Tony he was saying
trying to take notes he's elevated the
idea of taking notes in a lucid dream to
an art literally because he draws in the
lucid dream a portrait of the subject in
his case namely me and then he is able
to in the real world try to remember
what he drew and present it to the
subject in this case may take a look we
have a little bit of footage of this
Dave Green I'm an artist and I work with
lucid dreams
a lucid dream is a dream in which you're
aware of the fact that you're dreaming
I've had Fairly regular and spontaneous
lucid dreams ever since I was a child
I had quite bad nightmares and at some
point I learned to change the course of
the dream to deal with these nightmares
[Music]
sometimes people say you can control the
dream but it might be more accurate to
say you can influence the dream
as well as Conjuring drawings out of my
lucid dreams I also do portraits of
people
I'll meet the dream version of them in
my lucid dream I locate a Dream pen and
a dream piece of paper and I'll create
their portrait in the dream world and
then wake up and recreate that artwork
in Waking Life
it's quite hard to dream about someone
who you don't really know so a lot of
the time it'll be a random person who
contacts me on the internet
so what I'll do is I'll arrange a
conversation with them on Zoom hey hello
Brian any background on me I mean or do
you like to go in with a lot of
information or a little information or
what's your relationship like with your
your dreams so I'll get to know them a
little bit
just so it makes it easier to dream of
them
if I'm planning to meet a specific
person in my in my lucid dream there's a
few different rituals that I'll do to
help increase my chances I might pace
around the room a bit and rehearse the
actions that I'm intending to do in the
lucid dream I've never lose a dream I'm
gonna meet Ryan green I'm going to
create his portraits I might meditate
for 10 20 minutes before I went to bed I
might place the pen and paper
on my desk and literally just write my
goal for that lucid dream on the paper
I'll grab my pen and I'll put that in my
pajama pocket so when I roll over I
might kind of feel that on my leg it
sounds kind of ridiculous but that will
help me remember what I'm planning to do
drawing in a lucid dream is nothing like
drawing in Waking Life because
everything in a dream is in a constant
state of flux nothing is stable for more
than a couple of seconds until it
transforms into something else although
I'm aware of the fact I'm drawing In The
Dream Most of the content of the drawing
is out of my control it's like an
interaction between my conscious and my
unconscious mind playing itself out on
the page in real time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
started without any visual so I was just
feeling my way around usually the person
would just sort of appear and go Dave
here I am but it didn't happen
sounds weird but I kind of felt I felt
something I was like hang on that's
someone's face and then I told myself
that's going to be Brian Green and then
you kind of you emerged and from there
all the visuals kicked in that's great
that's great and then from there I held
up this piece of paper
and then some drawings started to appear
on the paper and that's so if I spent
around this is so when I told you it
wouldn't necessarily look like a
traditional portrait this kind of way
yeah I would say that it doesn't quite
look like a traditional Port today I
agree with that characterization so like
what am I looking at to be honest they
remain as mysterious to me as they do
too
to anyone most most of the time this is
my favorite one so I I met dream Brian
Greene the dream version of you and I
gave you a pen and paper oh you did okay
and you instructed me to draw me or you
instructed me to draw anything just draw
anything okay so that so that's that one
wow that's very cool it's quite funny
actually you started
scribbling but you didn't want to look
at the paper so you were looking away
like that
and you're just drawing like this and
you just scribbled a face and you were
drawing yourself Portrait by the way so
yeah yes it has a very psychedelic feel
to it it's funny doing this for you
because sometimes people are like they
have a way more sort of outlandish view
of what lucid dreaming is than I do so
they sort of relate to it like a cyclic
or something and I'm like I'm one of
your artists that sometimes I'm begging
people to like read listen to my artwork
I find it fascinating to see how various
influences filters through your brain
and emerges in this unusual context of
lucid dreaming but to go beyond that and
to read in some deeper reality into the
drawing that actually comes directly
from me or is telling me something about
my life that would be hard for me to go
that step the reason I like engaging in
lucid dreaming through artwork is
because art is all about asking
questions right it's not about settling
on answers and I think that is the most
healthy way for me to engage with lucid
dreaming I do it in like a playful way
and I just always keep an open mind and
I try to be comfortable with the
ambiguity and the Mystery of Dreams
so Tony I gather you actually know Dave
green and have been working with him
sending him various assignments to come
up with characters and lucid dreams and
interact with them so what do these kind
of exercises that we just saw and the
ones that you've done with him directly
what does it tell us about dream
characters and what does that tell us
about the brain that's Conjuring these
characters up indeed Dave and I have
been working together on these various
projects which I really aim to address
questions of well what is you know
characters in our dreams often act and
speak as if they had their own
perspectives their own intentions their
own feelings and so there were came the
idea I said well uh Dave instead of
drawing yourself ask dream characters to
do the drawings for you but also like if
they are sitting in front of you drawing
their perspective is 180 degrees from
yours so will the drawing make sense do
they have to turn it over to you and
just asking characters to draw I was
just also curious to know how do they
respond so as you see some of them like
um you know yourself in his dream uh
agree to the task but you know instantly
apparently I wanted to look away from
when I was drawing apparently that's
right but for instance in one dream he
said that the
character said oh no I can't do that and
when Dave asks him well why not he goes
well I'm from Czechoslovakia and so
there's there's this weird you know
these and and David was like where did
my brain come up with that but one lady
in his dream did a drawing gave it to
him and it was just a series of numbers
and so he asked her you know well this
is in a drawing she goes of course it is
you know but now it's up to you to
decipher what it means and so it's just
again it's very playful but it's also
instructive because he's aware that he's
dreaming he remembers he's very good at
remembering these instructions as easy
as they pertain to drawing but there's
an element which is always a surprise
that is what are these characters how
are they going to respond to these
requests and what are they going to
produce as a drawing so it's very
different from him intentionally drawing
it's sort of another part of his brain
that's sort of active doing this and
then showing them a finished product
that he's not aware till he sees it what
it is though his brain is producing it
so it's this uh interesting empirical
but also playful art science mixture in
this project that we're doing together
so Deidra what do you think about all
these characters that inhabit our minds
at night I mean what can they tell us
about ourselves and about the human
brain one of the studies I did that that
sort of told me the most about what
dream characters were started out as
something where
um I was trying to look at the dreams of
people who had what at that time was
called multiple personality disorder
it's now dissociative identity disorder
but they they have parts of themselves
that kind of pop out as if separate
personalities and often have amnesia for
each other's experiences and it's a rare
but really interesting Disorder so I did
this serve they asking clinicians if
they're patients that ever told them
dreams and and if so how the the
multiple personality interacted with
with dreaming and what I really noticed
was that if you hadn't known there were
multiples they were basically normal
dreams but sometimes one personality
would have another one show up as a
character in their dream and sometimes
in a morning three or four personalities
would wake up remembering the same dream
but each of them was in a different role
like one had been this little girl who
was scared that someone was going to
come and harm her and she was huddled
under the bed and one had been an adult
coming trying to soothe her and another
was another playful kid trying to
distract her and one was like trying to
diminish this little girl and and and
yet any one of them could have had those
dreams and it would have just seemed
like this you know what we often call
sort of dissociated in part of our our
self that dream characters are and so I
actually ended up concluding that maybe
multiple personality
it came a little bit from a sort of
using this ability to create all these
other selves that we naturally have in
REM sleep and when really stressed
beginning to to either neurologically
malfunction and do this awake or or call
upon it as you know as a useful defense
mechanism when awake but it just it made
me realize that we I as others had
really been talking about splitting off
parts of the cell for dissociating parts
of the self both for the dream
characters and for
um for the multiple personalities and
even in normal Waking Life we experience
kind of slightly different aspects of
our self but I think that in REM sleep
and uh and in in multiple personality
that whatever that mechanism that's
holding us together is is not working
the same has been yeah sort of let loose
and that's when all the different
characters or personalities show up
there we have to bring them together
rather than that's amazing and can I
follow up on that a little bit there's a
history
um Tibetan Buddhists who have a practice
called dream yoga and that has many
different components but part of it is
sometimes to experience a transformation
so the student is advised to have a
lucid dream and transform into another
creature and experience the world in
different ways and so that's part of the
general idea of how can we use our
dreams to help us improve and to perhaps
think differently about our Waking Life
by comparing it to our dream life and
the flexibility that is so readily
available in our lucid dreams is there
is there evidence that people have been
able to use dreams lucid dreams to
improve their performance and I don't
know sports music things of that sort
there is evidence for that but of course
it's been limited by the small number of
people that can have consistent lucid
dreams and I think we can do we can do
better with that but but yes you can use
your dream time to perhaps engage some
practice of a skill that you've been
working on during your waking time and
maybe just a little bit more effort
during your sleep time could be helpful
maybe you know if you're a gymnast and
you're practicing your routines over and
over again maybe it'd be helpful to
practice them in slow motion a bit and
you could do that or without gravity
practice them without grafting no
gravity there and just you know work on
the techniques a little bit more
carefully so your whole world is being
created by your brain without the
sensory input regulating things the way
our waking experiences so you can have
an experience that's completely real in
a dream and we kind of think that
contrasts with the real experience we
have when we're awake and the sensory
world is determining what we're
experiencing but those two experiences
they're actually the same quality of
experience for our subjective awareness
when we're experiencing a world and it
kind of shows you that well the waking
World experience it's in the same sense
produced by our brain just like our
Dream experiences are there's nothing
really different about them aside from
the sensory input that dictates a little
bit what happens but as far as the
feeling of being there and being
immersed in a world
we only need our brain for that we
actually don't need the sensory world
for that so you know if you spend a lot
of your time working on you know some
musical skill that you're developing
your brain is probably working on that
again during sleep but we can promote it
and you know if you do many things
during the day your brain might go off
in many different directions during the
night but maybe you'd like to Target it
to specific things you'd rather do that
would be helpful for you for your
psychological well-being and for your
problem solving things you're working on
that you want to come up with new
solutions for for example and you do
have lucid dreams right Deirdre I have
lucid dreams I naturally I'm a little
more more than average Lucid dreamer
like I maybe have three a year if I'm
not doing anything but when I use these
sort of original technique Steve Laberge
Advocates where you do daytime reality
checks you you think of something that's
different in your dreams like trying to
read text doesn't work in dreams for
many people or watches and clock run
oddly your light switches don't actually
change the lighting so you pick
something that doesn't work the same in
your dream and just periodically through
the day you try to read something or you
try to flip a light switch and then you
fall asleep kind of doing a general
dream incubation tonight in my dream I
want to be Lucid when I do that I have
about one a week I'd like to emphasize
dream incubation because I think it is
like the single most important and
really the easiest technique to optimize
some of these things we've been talking
about about creativity and problem
solving and getting something from your
dreams and the term incubation is
borrowed from the Greek dream temples
where people went and they would pray to
the god Oscar lapius who was both the
god of dreams and the god of healing for
dreams which were usually for medical
healing but but in some in some temples
in some eras they were just kind of for
problem solving dreams and they slept in
the temple but that this was called
incubation so modern Western
psychologists have a a sort of less
ritualized non-religious version of this
where we ask people to focus on what
they want to dream about and it can be
just a topic or person or place if
you're just trying to have a nice nice
dream or it can be a question you have
for yourself or it can be a problem
you're stuck on and if it's a problem it
can be a personal one about why you and
your spouse keep having this certain
pattern of arguments and what you could
do differently but it can be something
like if you're stuck on what is the
structure of benzene what does this
molecule look like I want to dream about
that and so you tell yourself you want
to dream about that just as a simple
verbal statement as you're falling
asleep you form a mental image of the
problem or question or person you want
to dream on because our dreams are so
visual that the visual image tends to
stay in memory and get through the
dreaming mind the very best a picture
related to what you want to dream about
is the last thing you look at on your
nightstand or a little collection of
objects but you just fall asleep
self-suggesting that you want a dream an
answer to a problem or simply on a topic
I use dream incubation more during the
pandemic than any other technique I did
a survey anxiety dreams went up so much
I have fifteen thousand pandemic dreams
that I wrote a book about and I did some
research on people were always asking
how they could have fewer anxiety dreams
so I found that just incubating positive
dreams choosing focusing on what you
wanted to dream about both
radically tended to alter the the
average dream content but also some
people who end up not recalling a dream
at all say oh but it's just such a
beautiful way to fall asleep like I sort
of have the experience of falling asleep
of thinking what I'd like to to dream
about so dream incubation I think is an
extremely powerful technique but jumping
off from that notion just the final
topic I want us to touch on is the
relationship between dreaming and
creativity and problem solving and there
are many examples that people speak
about throughout the world cultural
World scientific world like it's said
that Paul McCartney came up with the
melody for yesterday in a dream there's
a story that I know from science this uh
scientist Otto lowie who claimed to
figure out cellular communication
through a dream and delay of and
periodic table there's also this other
famous example of August kakule Germany
a chemist who figured out the chemical
structure of benzene in a dream so is
there much to this are these just
stories anybody have a thought on that
oh absolutely there's a lot to it I mean
I just I'd heard kind of the ones you
rattled off and maybe another dozen kind
of always repeated in every dream book
and so when I started researching dreams
and creativity and I both did some some
formal research but also wrote this book
called the committee of sleep which is
more anecdotal I I I combed the indexes
of old History of Science and books for
the word dream and started finding just
more and more that were not the retold
ones and I also put out a call to people
in different professions about whether
they had ever had a dream that was
important in their work Paul Horowitz
who's he's a full professor in both the
engineering and yeah yeah yeah and Paul
designs the controls for telescopes and
he was basically telling me that
whenever he is working on a telescope
problem and and only those for some
reason uh he does other kinds of
engineering but when he's working on a
problem that it's not one one main
problem the way the kecule example is
but it's a series of problems and that
he reliably always has a dream that
gives him a better solution than he has
and and he describes that uh that he'll
fur these dreams are very clear he
remembers them easily they're kind of
realistic he's looking over the shoulder
of a man who's trying to do whatever it
is and he sees the man kind of doing the
little things he's already tried as the
voice narrates that and then the voice
switches to so the best solution would
be and tells him something thing he had
not thought of before while he watches
the man put it together one MIT
mathematician told me about a math
problem he was trying to solve and John
Nash appeared and Einstein told a
computer programmer of all things like
how to write his program in another
dream so this kind of Super Wise Man
figure is common well I'm still waiting
I'm still waiting for Einstein to show
up in in my dream and give me some
insight but Tony have you solved any
problems in your sleep is that something
you've experienced
uh no I I've created problems but I
haven't solved any uh no not not not
personally
um but I think you know to come back to
your question about is there something
to this as theater was saying absolutely
I think you know some of these cases
might be disputed where they you know
they they reported the discovery 20
years later that it came in a dream or
whatever but there's enough of this
material anecdotally and otherwise to
suggest that this is this is something
that can happen that is but you got to
keep in mind these individuals who have
these discoveries or breakthroughs or
insights
are working on these problems you know
intensely sometimes not for weeks or
months in some cases for years uh like a
periodic table of the elements you know
so now in some of these cases the
solution isn't contained in the dream
directly but once these people wake up
and then they reflect on the content of
the dream the solution shows up and I
think dreaming as a whole has been
slowly through generations
devalued we sort of lost touch with
maybe what it the dreams as a product
can do for us and sharing dreams
recalling dreams
um trying to facilitate Solutions dream
incubation and so on I think that if it
was more respected and collectively
practice
um well put it this way I don't think
the world would be a worse place but it
might be a little bit better or at least
individually it would be but we sort of
lost track of that right I mean if you
go back even Salvador Dali had a
technique where you know it'd hold a
heavy key slip into sleep his hand would
open because he was sleeping he dropped
the key he would smash a plate and he
would then be inspired by that Twilight
space between being awake and being
asleep the hypnagogic state and would
create wonderful artwork inspired by
what he had there but but Ken I just
want to turn to you I mean what is your
perspective you've actually done studies
where you've you've watched people
do better at solving a problem by virtue
of
incubating that problem in their dream
or in their sleep stage so how effective
is this as an approach to dealing with
real world issues we uh agree that with
the idea that an intention to have a
particular dream you know dream
incumbation can work but it's not always
dependable and so we wanted to go One
Step Beyond that and see if we could
really provoke people to think about
problems that they hadn't solved and it
was related to Brian what you were
talking about earlier the evidence for
uh the importance of dreaming for coming
up to solutions to problems or creating
new music or new other ideas it's mostly
anecdotal so there hadn't been a lot of
studies to really show that that can
work and so we wanted to provoke it in a
series of studies these were run by
Kristen Sanders who was a PhD student in
Mark Beeman's lab and his lab
specializes in creativity and problem
problem solving so they have a whole set
of small little problems that they can
give to people like the one with these
sets of circles uh in the shape of a
triangle
triangle is pointing up and the problem
is can you move three of those circles
to change it to a triangle that's
pointing down and Kristen would give
people about two minutes to try to solve
this and and many other problems and and
they're hard and often people don't come
up with the solution in the two minutes
and that's what we wanted because then
she took these problems and asked
whether people could saw them after a
period of sleep overnight sleep and so
what she did is each problem that she
presented to people came with a little
music soundtrack and they had to
associate which music went which with
problem and then during their sleep they
went home and we gave them technology
that could record their sleep when they
were in slow wave sleep
some of the music was presented in fact
for half of the problems they were given
and then they came back to the lab the
next day and we asked well what's their
chance of solving the problems now and
as predicted the chances of solving went
way up for the problems that we
reactivated during sleep so we showed
that if a problem is reactivated during
sleep it increases the likelihood of
getting the solution the next day but
our study was the full night of sleep
and we couldn't find out is it because
of REM sleep or or a slow wave sleep or
a different stage but we did show that
if we had people reactivate problems
that we picked a subset of the problems
that they had not solved the day in the
evening session when they came back in
the morning we could increase the
chances of them solving problems so
perhaps creativity can be harnessed to
do that either with Our intention before
we go to sleep or maybe even with some
technology that can provoke us to use
our our sleep in in this particular way
so that's exciting but it also raises a
question and it's a penultimate one that
I'd like to ask all of you which is look
if you can influence somebody while
they're sleeping to better solve a
problem you are influencing them in some
surreptitious way for them to have
certain kinds of thoughts now that can
be used for good it can be used for ill
right and so do do any of you worry that
as you become better at engineering and
incubating certain kinds of things while
people are sleeping or dreaming that you
know big corporations I don't have to
name them but you know I have this
little thing by my bedside and I say I
don't even want to say the name because
my iPad will probably speak up if I say
hey Siri you know there's a there's a
speaker there where you could imagine
surreptitiously having all sorts of
things pumped into your head while you
are asleep that geared toward I don't
know buying this or that product or
things of that sort does that worry you
as a direct action in which this kind of
research might go
it should worry you if you keep the TV
on all night while you're sleeping so I
wouldn't recommend that yeah I mean
people have been doing that since the
dawn of radio falling asleep listening
to things although I I I I believe that
Tony and I very much disagree on these
so he he certainly will probably want to
say something but there have been very
recently some of my colleagues have been
saying that they that they think this is
very possible and alarming and there was
there was a call that some of them tried
to get a senator to introduce something
to the Federal Trade Commission to make
it illegal to to do exactly that to play
things over speakers it to activate your
speaker and play ads at you while you
were dreaming to to do any sort of
involuntary dream stuff and I think that
that's really naive about what already
exists they did not seem to have looked
at the Federal Trade commission's
guidelines which are very clear that any
deceptive advertising is forbidden that
you cannot do covert things where
someone doesn't know they're being
advertised to that's why we see all
these things that even though they look
a little bit like fake news stories they
say paid advertisement in huge letters
across the top because otherwise they'd
be in violation so they cannot turn your
speakers on to play ads just for your
sleep without your very clearly if you
want to be paid to listen to ads during
your sleep that would not be illegal as
long as you're properly informed but
you're talking on that well I I disagree
to the to I agree with some points but I
also think that this technology is
evolving very quickly and so I think
it's naive to think that just playing
things over the speakers you can use
smells you can condition you can use
tactile more and more people are are
sleeping with wearables that monitor
their heart rate respiration rate we're
getting
some wearables that are getting fairly
good at detecting broad sleep stages so
we have data collected on our sleep and
so one concern is how is this being used
and by whom and not just now but like in
five years ten years and so what in in a
letter that was signed by over uh 40
sleep and dream researchers where we
express these concerns is let us not
wait like we did with other waking
Technologies where now we go oh privacy
issues and this and that where it's a
little late let's try to be proactive
and see what's coming down the line so
I'll just give you two very benign
examples but where again it's not clear
when you even if you consent that you're
aware of what you consent to so in one
study that people smokers come into the
sleep lab and unbeknownst to them while
they were sleeping they got just for a
very short period a pairing of smoking a
smoke smell with either rotten eggs or
rotten fish now this was just for a few
seconds in one phase of sleep so it's
not very long and when they woke up
people in the morning they asked you
know do you recall any stigma whatever
most people did not
but they were also had to keep track of
their smoking and other behaviors before
and after the study but just having this
pairing which they were had no idea had
taken place they diminished their
smoking by 30 percent in the week that
followed the study but even more
worrisome because it's the power of your
sleeping brain if you do this pairing
while people are awake it has no impact
on their smoking
you can have people say what do you
prefer Skittles or M Ms and people you
know I prefer M Ms well you have them
sleep in the lab and you just present
tones with Skittles
um over the night and when they wake up
in the morning you ask them what do you
prefer Eminems or Skittles go you know
what I like Skittles more and you ask
him why they go I don't know I thought
I'd prefer the Menendez but now and so
these are just trivial examples but
last year uh at this uh American uh
marketing convention where there's over
400 different marketing companies almost
80 percent of them said that in the next
three years they are planning of
developing using something to do with
dream engineering or sleep manipulation
for advertising so this is coming and
our concern is not let's not wait to see
if it works or not before we react let's
try to be proactive and again it's hard
for me to understand in many of our
colleagues what exactly we are
consenting to if things are done while
we are asleep because when you are
asleep you are not consciously aware of
what is going on and you're often even
amneshic for whatever took place and so
that's to me very unique and the other
place I I agree with Deirdre that
there's a lot other concerns with waking
and fake news and this and that but at
least there you can mix our sort of
informed decision or you are aware of
what is going on or not ours to me Leaf
should be a sacred Refuge like look
you're messing with our minds and
bombarding just sleep you know do you
want to be dreaming and have
advertisements you know on in your
dreams or you know give me ten dollars
and you'll have ad-free dreams
um now this sounds like sci-fi but I
don't really think it is if we look down
five ten years at the the pace at which
these Technologies are being developed
now they can be used and are being
developed for great reasons but like
many things they can be used for good
and for Less good and our point is just
maybe we should take a step back and
think about this and be proactive rather
than reactive you know a decade from now
so I have two two things I'd like to say
back to that though which are first of
all I don't disagree with the idea that
none of those things should be allowed
but I really I just keep thinking that
maybe Tony and some of the others have
really not read the current FTC
guidelines about deceptive advertisement
and convert covert advertisements
legal experts go through it and it is
not clear that it applies to what we do
or not do while we are asleep and it's
also that the it's aimed at the kind of
advertisement that we are exposed to
while we are awake and now we're talking
about this how does this apply to
tactile Sensations in your sleep how
does this apply to VI you know there's
many kinds of ways of engineering or
manipulating uh sleep that we know that
is going to be integrated in wearables
in mattresses in smart devices and this
is Beyond just what kind of advertising
it's can we even manipulate this can we
package this with other things and Adam
Horowitz of MIT has even detailed here's
many scenarios which are not that
far-fetched and that you know if you
even you consent it to this here's some
of the consequences which no one could
anticipate so it's not clear even what
you are consenting and so yes the rules
are there but like in many things like
for copyright rules a lot of them had to
be updated no one's saying well there's
copyright rules so the artist should you
know be okay with digital music or
whatever so a lot of the laws we put in
place were for certain circumstances
certain Technologies these are evolving
very quickly and maybe we should make
sure that they are well aligned one with
the other
different experts because the ones I
talk to
say that it that they that the FTC has
never been as specific as you can't do
this during sleep or dreams but but it's
stated in Broad and very general
language and well listen there's always
a gap between what the guidelines are
and what's enforced so we have to think
about that sense
I aren't going to get around that yes
indeed although the FTC slaps people
advertisers with some amazingly High
fines I mean that is why when when they
write those fake news stories they put
that paid advertisement thing up there
pretty reliably because because you know
they can be out of business with the
size so Ken let's let me just get your
perspective on this well I've I've taken
the side with Tony I was one of the
signatories and the reason is I think we
need to as we make scientific progress
continually think about the ethics and
the ramifications of our work and so I
think it's not a panic mode sort of
thing it's just like well let's think
through what our discoveries are going
to lead to what are the unforeseen
possible consequences and I think it's
always important to think those through
and whether it does require new laws
well that's that's a later question for
the legal profession to worry about but
I think as scientists we're just wanting
to be sure we're also always thinking
through what's what's possible from the
from the discoveries we make and how it
could be misused yeah
it was the call for action with the FTC
that that uh all for Action was just one
and to me really minor part and and so I
don't want to over Focus the major part
is here's a bunch of people working in
the field and who are expressing
concerns about what may lay down the
pipeline and so maybe we should have
independent of the laws ethical
guidelines even as researchers as yeah
no I actually think that more of that is
being done with research subjects than
than could be done with political
manipulation or advertising so yeah I
mean we do have a lot of research ethics
guidelines but whether those need to be
updated for the technology that exists
and I think whether they need to be
separate from dreaming what I think
sci-fi is the comparison to the power of
something discovered in for dreams and
the power of what's happening with all
this waking technology I I just I don't
think is going to be cost effective to
do it the dream way so there's something
special going on in our sleeping brain
that does not have the same effect when
you do the exact same intervention while
you are awake and there is our concern
we have we're just starting to discover
all the incredible things that the brain
does while it sleeps and when we start
manipulating and playing with that well
it might have effects that are much
stronger or different than when you do
this in a way and so it's just again a
call of well maybe this should get us
thinking as scientists and as citizens
of the world who are trying to develop
techniques and see where is leaving us
and how maybe we should be weary of
these steps we're taking and to think
through their implications clear to the
point that matters to to all of you and
I presume to the community of
researchers more generally and
definitely it needs is more thought and
more discussion I do want to move on to
one final question which is this so Tony
you made reference to the fact that
there was a time when dream research was
perhaps not given the kind of attention
that that it now seems that it really
does deserve I'm wondering all of you do
you feel that this research will
ultimately give us insight into say the
big questions of Consciousness the hard
problem of Consciousness I mean there's
been so much work done in the neural
correlates of Consciousness when awake
typically is this perhaps another part
of that puzzle that really needs to be
integrated to get the fullest
understanding of Consciousness Ken maybe
uh start with you well you know I I
think if we're going to open up that keg
of worms there's a whole lot to talk
about because as a memory researcher I
think we really gain a lot by
understanding the difference between
conscious memory and unconscious memory
and in fact we sometimes make an
assumption okay you go to sleep and
you're not conscious inches and then you
wake up in your conscious again
I don't know that I buy that actually
because what we know is when you wake up
you don't have a memory for what
happened during that intervening eight
hours but it doesn't mean you weren't
conscious during that time of course you
were probably conscious of experience a
dream at some point but even the other
stages we don't know
what conscious experiences were like at
that moment we only know you don't
remember them later so I think
inferences about our Consciousness
during sleeper on really weak territory
if we only have the later report but I
think there is to connect it to all the
other research and Consciousness science
of course we can bring to bear methods
for looking at the brain and what is the
brain doing in these different states
and how does that relate to brain
function and normal waking state or
brain function during anesthesia or
brain function during a coma and look
for commonalities that try to help us
understand what's happening in the brain
during these times when you have the
ability to have conscious experiences
compared to other times where you seem
not to have that ability so I think it
it should be part of the broader picture
but it's a big picture that we can
hardly handle in the last year yeah sure
absolutely but thank you for that
Deirdre any brief thoughts on dreaming
Consciousness yeah I mean I I really
like that old-fashioned analogy about
how science is like a bunch of people
going into a dark room and feeling
around for what's there and finally
finding the light switch and turning it
on that shows them another door that
they can walk into another dark room
that each each thing we discover like
presents at least as many new questions
that that we can explore so I certainly
think that technology is taking off
right now and some some of the future of
of dream research in the near future is
going to be about app apps and wearables
um I really think that what's even more
important is that some of the stuff that
we have solid research on about some of
the more low-tech method like which
techniques of dream interpretation
really are helpful to a client and which
aren't and things like that dream
incubation doesn't work all the time but
it really can focus your dream toward
topics and the low-tech version does
well so I think that any sort of
education on what we already know is the
most important piece but I certainly
think it's going in a a tech direction
for at least so hopefully this program
will help in that regard and Tony you
want to take us out final thoughts on
dreaming and Consciousness sure well I I
view dreaming as a special form of
Consciousness and again why does the
brain create these experiences that that
we can sometimes recall the interesting
thing with dreams that you're you're com
like you can compare what's going on or
very soon what's going on in the brain
the moment you become aware that you're
dreaming so you have this Consciousness
but then self-reflectiveness kicks in
and so I think this kind of knowledge
which we're slowly starting to piece
together uh with Innovative not only
techniques but methodologies
experimental methodologies like the one
Ken with this two-way communication with
lucid dreamers will start giving us
maybe a different as theater Saying A
different light that goes on in a
different area but also I think really
offering answers that starts answering
the question of dream Consciousness and
then it allows us to see how does this
maybe relate to different forms of
waking consciousness and so I think
it'll
certainly help us maybe better
understand what a big answer to such a
big question as what is the nature of
Consciousness during wakefulness might
look like and what is satisfying in
terms of explaining this phenomena well
thank you all so much for this deep
penetrating conversation on dreaming the
brain Consciousness you know where where
the mentating human mind meanders after
midnight so thank you so much for
joining us look forward to the results
of your research going forward thank you
very much sweet dreams thank you yes
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you